rich
dave congratulations you've made it to
the final good job
it's a second shot at the title forged
and fire champion and that check for ten
thousand dollars
now we're sending you back to your home
forges to create an iconic blade from
history
rich you got any ideas i don't have a
clue dave what do you want it to be
lightsaber
[Music]
[Laughter]
let's see it
the hook sword nice
long before the hook sword was featured
in films like crouching tiger hidden
dragon it was wielded by the shaolin
monks in ancient china
established around 495 a.d the shaolin
monastery was a hub of martial arts
where buddhist monks were trained in
self-defense using everything from
common tools to versatile weapons like
the hook sword
the sword's curved blade allowed the
user to trip or disarm opponents
its crescent guard could be used to
slash or block blows
and if used in a pair the swords could
be linked at their hooks to increase the
weapon's deadly reach
good luck blade smiths we'll see you in
five days
good luck
[Music]
all right let's get to work
today's day one i'm excited to be at my
own shop and have a little more comfort
in my home shop i don't have will
screaming at me every 45 minutes
that could be an advantage could be a
disadvantage
that's hot making this sword is kind of
tough because it's the swiss army knife
of swords it's got a lot of edges it's
got a lot of blocking points
today what i'm going to do is i'm going
to make the crescent part of the blade
just to work myself into it
it's probably one of the easier parts of
the sword i'll save the complicated
parts for last
i like it
so day two plan of attack's gonna be
simple get the main portion of the sword
cleaned up to bear steel
and then he treat
looks like it's coming together i don't
have a quench tank large enough to do
the whole thing
i'll do two heat treats
i'll do the main post of the sword first
oh
it's straight
and then i'll do that hook secondly
if i do it this way the heat will just
hit this part
the big concern that i've got is
overheating the transition part from the
hook down into the main shaft of the
sword it's too soft then on impact it
can inevitably bend and uh i don't want
that
we shall see
right now i'm happy about the sword
and i'd like to get everything heat
treated by tonight
in order to get the heat treat right i'm
gonna have to make a bigger forge so i'm
gonna use these drums that i got from
breaking bad and turn it into a heat
treat forge
this is it
here goes nothing
i heard weird sounds
[Music]
freaking beautiful
not a single twister ben
i think those noises may have been
coming from the forge barrels settling
because the heat treat turned out
beautiful
today ought to be a pretty fun day
everything's heat-treated everything's
tempered just got to get a handle put on
it
sharpen it
it should cut it should hack it should
stab it should do whatever they're going
to throw at it i don't want to see any
failure in this
it cuts
i'd say it out of work
but i'm really not looking forward to
what the judges are gonna put this thing
up again
slapping it up against this or cutting
that i really don't know but you know
we're gonna find out soon enough
i don't like watermelon
[Music]
today i'm just debating on what type of
handle to put on this thing
beautiful
i ended up going with a wrap i i never
did macrame
i got the handle wrapped i got a little
blood on my sword
as far as the sword design goes it's
kind of silly
it's got a lot of sharp edges on it it
seems a little dangerous to me
it's sharp everywhere
well
it will cut
we'll see if it will kill
[Music]
bladesmiths to test the edge and
sharpness of your blade i will slash one
time on each of these satami mats filled
with rice if they're sharp it should cut
cleanly through rich you're up first are
you ready heck yeah
i think i'm gonna do well the sword
sharp there are no flaws there's no
inherent problems with it
nice
pretty cool
well rich
it is a light and sharp sword you can
definitely maneuver with it for close
quarter but as you can see it can slash
cleanly through these mats
it definitely
will cut it will good job
dave you're up next are you ready yes
sir let's do this
[Music]
dave
your blade's a little bit heavier
it's sharp enough to cut but not sharp
enough to cut all the way through
because of the weight of the weapon when
you're extending and you have a point
pointing back at you there's a little
bit of concern of how you're gonna be
controlling the blade
but overall sir
good job
thank you
rich has a point i don't have a point
yet so it's one to zero so i have to
farewell in the second test dave
so gentlemen to test the strength of
your weapon i'm gonna take two blows
against our terracotta warriors here if
your blade is strong enough it should
survive the impact with minimal damage
rich are you ready i am okay
[Music]
well rich
wonderfully light weapon very very fast
you've got a little deformation on the
edge but it didn't ship
picked up a bit of a bend
but not too far out of true yeah well
done
all right dave your turn
i ain't gonna watch this it's not gonna
happen so uh i'm just using my ears
[Music]
i'm good with that
when i see dave's sword shatter the
terracotta dummies i'm feeling nervous
well dave a much heavier weapon
you can see it just powered right
through the terracotta with no problem
whatsoever
it's still right and tight and true and
everything
a little deformation but again we're
hitting terracotta
well done
awesome
[Music]
rich david the judges have scrutinized
every aspect of your work and your
weapons performances and they've made
their final decision
david
congratulations you are the forest and
fire champion good job you're kidding
right
no not
rich unfortunately your weapon did not
make the cut rich i love what you
brought us
and during the testing you and david
ended up pretty much even
both of your blades flexed during the
caracata strength test
but yours kept the bend in it didn't
come back to true so that's why we're
sending you home today okay
rich it's time for you to surrender your
weapon and leave the forge
thanks guys i'm completely happy with
the sword that i made but right now i
feel a little defeated i feel a little
beat up
the first thing i'm doing when i get
home is i'm going to sleep
i can really use a nap
dave
came in just shy the first time you were
here now you're a forged and fire
champion who's also receiving a check
for ten thousand dollars how do you feel
right now i honestly don't know right
now i'm still kind of elated at the
moment
i like the way the edge held up on that
didn't take any chips or chunks out of
it
thank you well congratulations
[Applause]
now i've actually proven to myself that
yes i can do it and getting to go home
as a champion that's
that's pretty cool
you